yeah
um okay so question
um pertaining but a little bit going
back to only fans
okay so men how many bodies is too many
bodies for you to wife a girl
yeah age has to be you have to give me
an age
um how old are you I'm 28. okay let's do
it girl you're age 28 28 it has to be
below 10 low 10 28. below 10.
my heart was like it has to be below
tennis though
does okay this this is not this is not
so much to do with my age or this is
like more me as a person
[Music]
um the way I am and you should know if
she's more than five then it's too much
how old are you 25. and if if it was the
same age as you yeah but then then again
like I said it's to do with my
preferences
we'll dive into it anyway no I'm not
insecure like we'll get into it we'll
get into it
okay you guys need context
okay yes go ahead
it's a wife
thank you
holy how old am I I'm 26. okay so well
we're gonna let's say you know you went
28 year old girl yeah
um
bro say it with chest don't be shy bro
no I'd say 10 10. okay yeah
girls ladies
ladies you guys care about that I don't
really care to be honest yeah
I mean I don't care to an extent if it's
like a guy who's in more than a hundred
oh yeah if it's crazy
that's like that's just yeah I mean
that's just sleeping with girls for the
sake of sleeping with girls which there
are a lot of guys who do that loads yeah
but like as long as this two figures
okay
um it um do I what's my number yeah
I don't have a number yeah you don't
care no no I don't care because if I
meet someone and then and we connect and
my personal person I'm not gonna judge
you in your past I cannot I can't be
that personal during your past because
now we're together and we're moving
forward you're past your past but
there's certain names or certain people
if you have been with I might be like oh
I can't do that okay what about you do
you care uh I'm 19 so like age range
dating wise I used to go like my age to
like I guess 22 free so I would usually
say I don't like numbers doesn't really
matter but like if it's getting to the
point where it's like nearly like 20 or
something that's when I'm more like oh
my God you've yeah been alive for 19
years and you've done more than anything
then I'm like yeah let me like hold the
brain so I have I have some stats for
you guys so if a girl if a girl is a
virgin okay she has an 80 chance of
being in a happy marriage after 10 years
so weird after 10 years yeah after 10
years using 80 chance so what between
one and ten she's not happy or what no
she is happy
if a girl waits till she's married to
have sex yeah she has an 80 chance of of
being happy in a marriage after 10 years
definitely and if a girl sleeps with
more than five people what do you think
it drops down to boy okay wait who I
said 40 40 20 not 50. so 50. so it's 25
percent
if you sleep with more than five people
your chance goes down to a 25 chance of
being happy do you know the reasons why
there isn't I have a theory no no so so
the reasons why is because
um
basically like a Girl Wants to Marry Her
First Choice and I think as women we can
all say we can think of a girl who is
dating the new guy but she really wants
the ex it doesn't matter who she's dead
and you we can all think of somebody
right it doesn't matter who she's dating
how nice she's treating her she wants
the ex the more X's there are the more
men the new guy can't live up to so
basically the men are frustrated because
girls get ran through in their in their
20s and then in their 30s they're like
oh who's gonna put a ring on this now so
you'll say and they're walking away
because half a woman over 30 are single
and childless but then yeah I'm
definitely one of those people but um
are you saying because you're you're
it's to do with sex right and not so if
I'm just dating multiple men it's no
issue but the minute I start sleeping
multiple men it becomes an issue because
my thing is I could date multiple men
some could take me out some that take me
out and then I can compare my my new
boyfriend to the exit look after me in
that way well the the thing is women
Bond through sex so we release a hormone
that men don't through sex so it sort of
bonds us to them and men don't release
that hormone they bond to women through
quality time I want to say and loyalty
that's that's what men Bond through
but I think the reason that that
percentage would be so high if it's like
say the first guy that you've met yeah
you've only been exposed to sex with one
guy so but I think you haven't all like
Sexes I feel like everyone like with
their first whoever you've lost your
virginity
this is something biological yeah
everything with everything we do no
matter whether it's sex whether it's
buying stuff
did the Paradox of choice Yeah the more
the more Choice a human being has the
less likely you are to be able to make a
proper decision so if you have three
things and you pick one you're more
happy to be happy you're more likely to
be happy with that choice if you have 24
things no matter how good those things
are you're always gonna think I could
have gone for that or I could have gone
for that I could go for that and that
goes for everything and girls are are so
a guy will go down and looks for sex but
he's never going to be seen in public
with those girls so a lot of girls that
are five and six fives and sixes are
sleepings with sleeping with a guy
that's an eight nine or ten she thinks
she's on she's on his level she's not
he's just sleep like he's not gonna be
seen in public with you and so a lot of
times a girl can't replace the guy that
she was sleeping with for a while
because she wasn't on his level and then
she asks the next guy to pay for her
mistakes in the past and she's and and
she's traumatized from it because the
more people that you know a girl goes
through the more traumatized she is
because the more social value she loses
it's not even like social that's true
that's true but what I was talking about
is like the more likely she's gonna have
had a bad breakup or a toxic
relationship or get cheated on and then
you have to deal with it 100 that's why
I think they say that men are judged but
the quantity of women they can get
whilst women are judged with the calip
of land they can keep yeah so they say
go and speak with it though
sorry yep it's so they say I have a
question for you though so do you think
when a man has sex or when a woman has
sex that they both objectively are the
same thing do you know what I honestly
cannot speak on that because I you guys
have said something that you guys have
said basically that you know women
connect with men they sleep with and I
don't necessarily do that if every man I
sleep
so I can't necessarily comment on that
because that's not necessarily my Norm
my Norm is very freeing
um but
I forgot my point now but what I want to
say is that
I don't I don't think it's about the sex
but it's the multiple people I feel like
sometimes we really put we really put
emphasis on it being the sex because I I
I've got friends that are virgins and
they're and they're 30 plus and they
still have they still have been through
toxic stuff and other stuff with men and
they are virgins so my thing is if we're
going oh yeah I've got friends I've got
friends
just say that
when you're my friend you haven't got
like trust me um the most freeing person
ever yeah but what I've realized is for
them their trauma is that they're not
giving up so then they're because I'm
having sex with men they're now going
through other issues well okay there is
issues that come with being an older
virgin because like the value of a
Virginia a virgin it goes with youth
right like like so an old virgin isn't
as valuable as a young virgin a lot of
virgins price themselves out of the
market because they think they're worth
more than they are so you could be a
virgin but how do you look
like no no no
years if if you're a virgin if you don't
look good to him if you're if you're
dating a guy out of your league but I
think as girls we often like lie to each
other because we like gas each other up
more than you know we're not really
honest about looks but I also feel like
with the whole looks thing if you're all
convinced she said look good looking
person I do feel like it wipes all your
wrongs like literally if you are you and
also like there's two things you're a
pretty girl your lungs are your wrongs
of it enough whether you've done anime
except if some man will push all the
Cycles you're pretty you're you're
you're correct in some people have
pretty privilege so attractive men get
to be more of an [ __ ] they get away
with it right pretty girls get to do
more ho [ __ ] and they get away with it
it's just part like Lori Harvey she
still could have married Michael B
Jordan Michelle no [ __ ] though she just
dated a couple of like a million rappers
million or not she's I mean I mean I
mean but it takes a certain it takes a
certain type of girl to deal with future
why would you why would you long term do
that that's that's the issue that's the
whole conversation owned still a future
being my number whatever that's all
different conversation right but I'm
saying it says it says something about
her character
I don't know because if you're dating
these men thinking like she's actually
dating men like she's like she's not
like running through different men or
doing whatever she's actually she's
actually going on vacation they're doing
things why can't she keep them
I I don't I think she but she dropped
Michael though she didn't want he's 35.
and she doesn't want to be married right
now but I'm saying that's that's why men
don't want a wife hoes is because hoes
don't stay they always return back to
the streets because they're addicted to
the attention one man's hoe is another
man's housewife so it really depends on
what a bit that's what you're saying
London I can move to Newcastle not be at
home how are you going to find out
you're not you're not incorrect some
you're right some girls get away with it
but the problem is it's the damage to
yourself is above all you can you can
you can trick a guy sure okay that's
that's possible but yeah but the I I've
talked to older women and they all say
the hoes get divorced first because they
can't stay they're addicted to the
attention and they're not great mothers
so you build that character and that
character goes with you everywhere so
you can move to a different country and
you just gonna you can relive that cycle
all over again because that's your
character so what the wives who were
sellers in the past can't stay but if
the husbands were to be a hoe ever
yeah are they the same or are they can
they stare because if they've had all
these other options they're used to the
attention as well now so um partially
you're probably like I think I do think
guys that sleep around are more likely
yeah like if I had to guess but but it's
different because men and women are
different and so they say that a guy a
girl sleeping with one guy is the
equivalent of a guy's 19. like when you
look at his marital happiness the the
ideal is Virgin so two virgins is the
ideal that is the highest marriage rates
I I agree I think that's the ideal but
the the thing is with with men when they
get to nine Partners versus six their
marital happiness goes up not down
yeah so there's not really as much of a
difference are these are these who are
these stats based on here we go
America's Americans or the UK based on
all colors of One race if you want
roller tomasi does a really good episode
where his name's roller tomasi he does a
really great episode where he links all
of the studies but it's based on
multiple studies in in with different
sample sizes in different places and
they're surveying people
I like to know okay because I think
stats and stuff and surveys are amazing
and I love them but also about you asked
about the environment or what they're in
but if you're doing a multi if it's a
multiple range of people and cultures
and groups that's great because then I
get to the holistic point of view if
you're talking about like a like a
straight man and a gay man I'm pretty
sure they have not got the same
necessarily the same kind of views or
values or even experiences well I met
them in different but this is kind of
one of those things that I didn't even
really need to see a study to me it's
like common sense like women since the
beginning of time men have had multiple
wives and women have had one strong man
it's I want to say the status eating oh
my gosh what is it there's 40 of women
reproduced historically were 80 amended
so it's like two men to every one woman
is possible for us to evolve from that
because I think we have yeah it's about
it's written up into our DNA just look
at the biology component of who we are
like you have to think the whole of
human civilization in 2022 now things
are different no no we're we're sleeping
with the same guy still if you look at
the dating app data um 100 of women want
20 of men and sometimes it's even
smaller than that if you want a guy
that's over six foot that's fifteen
percent of men if you want them to make
a certain amount of money that's that's
a smaller percentage of men if you want
a certain ethnicity that's a smaller
percentage of men if you want like women
are sleeping with the same men today
um one out of one out of three men under
30 are virgins are haven't had sex in a
year say that again one out of three men
under 30 are either virgins or haven't
had sex in a year wow that's hard to
believe
no but there's once you once you see it
you can't unsee it and so as a girl
there's a whole group of men we just
don't see think about when you're in
school there was a small select group of
guys that everybody knew about the rest
of them just were invisible think about
it or even when you walk into a room
like you'll you'll find that like you'll
be able to remember people and you maybe
there might be a guy who go oh I
remember you from this event yeah
[Music]
I know I know I know one woman yeah
you used to go to a gym that um that I
went to yeah and she she was sexually
free and she she made it known everyone
knew about it and she's sexually free
and
um I can't tell you how many guys from
the gym she she slept with and then
um the thing is about men we talk as
much as some women think we don't but we
talk and then we say oh yeah yeah so I
came to a point where she was she was
dating not sleeping but actually dating
someone from the same gym and
the other the other men that had already
slept with her started talking about her
and we just we just thought oh we looked
at him and thought well what are you
doing with yourself we looked at him as
the loser it came to the point where she
was now requesting marriage and then
because word has already come around he
already knew
um that she had slept with all these
other all these others men in Prior he
did not want to marry her and what
happened was
um even when he came down to her
children because she had I think uh
three or four children she would look
for a babysitter for her children to go
and sleep not with her boyfriend but
other men so the the the sexual addition
addiction was already there so I say
that to say this like when
when you are sexually free as a lot of
these well we're calling them actors
[Music]
we're calling them actors when you are
sexually free you have to know that it
will come a point in time where you may
not want to do that anymore and as men I
don't want to know that you slept with
my bedroom you know I don't I don't I
don't need to know that you know I don't
it for me it's not a fact it's not a
thing where
um I would want I would accept it in my
household so I don't feel like a lot of
these actors aren't only fans or what
like they think about that as many of
you know I was just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible